what's up guys so as you guys already
know GPU prices are insanely high right
now due to the high demand from miners
and gamers this has led to anxiousness
for the next series of the GPUs to come
out from Nvidia we have a mine dedicated
card codenamed Turing and a consumer
series called ampere and an enthusiast
GPU called water coming out later this
year but what about from AMD well there
isn't any rumors suggesting that there
will be a mine dedicated GPU from AMD
but AMD is notorious for releasing a GPU
refresh every year
unlike Nvidia only releases new GPUs
once every couple of years for many
months now AMD GPUs have not even been a
consideration for many gamers because
its prices have been out of the roof for
most of its lifetime
at first the 580 was actually a good
competition for 1060 and a 570 and 560
were good options too but for many
months now the Oryx series has only
benefited miners as a result what is AMD
planning for the 600 series of graphics
cards and how are they trying to make it
oriented towards gamers instead of
miners however at the same time AMD is
not known for dramatic upgrades between
the GPU series so what should you expect
well unfortunately the 600 series will
probably just be a small upgrade over
the 500 series hopefully it would take
advantage of the GDD r6 memory like
Nvidia ampere and rx 680 which should be
the flagship of the consumer series will
hopefully be at the level of the gtx
2060 part of the ampere series of Nvidia
the 580 was pretty much identical to the
1060 so hopefully we can expect this as
well this way the 670 will be similar to
the GTX 20 50 TI or 2063 gigabyte card
and the 660 will be equivalent to 20 50
unfortunately I don't think the serious
it would be a huge step forward it will
simply be another option for budget and
mid-level
but at the same time that's not
necessarily a bad thing well this
doesn't make invidious quit and make
them bring out their best similar to how
AMD is making endo feel right now this
does give it consumer more options and
more options are always a good thing
this way gamers can choose between a 680
or 2060 based on which one is cheaper
instead of being forced into one another
big advantage AMD brings to the table is
AMD freesync monitors and are at a much
more reasonable price than Nvidia g-sync
motors this will help gamers save some
money on the monitor side or get a tech
knowledge that they were previously not
even considering most importantly
hopefully these new six-hour series
cards will ease that market demand and
make graphics cars in general more
accessible to gamers at release these
GPUs will be retailed for MSRP so that
is a huge plus hopefully AMD designs
them in a way at the 600 series cars
won't be useful to minors
hopefully AMD even considers making a
dedicated mining card like Nvidia to
avoid losing mining market at the same
time while also benefiting the gaming
market Myers bring in a lot of revenue
for AMD s so I think that's probably
what they're planning to do
unfortunately however even if AMD is
successful in pulling away all the
miners from gaming oriented GPUs the GPU
prices for gamers will probably still go
up due to gamers themselves many gamers
have been holding out on buying GPUs
gutte ad outrageous prices for the past
couple of months and as a result many of
these gamers will buy these cards right
on release and test price that these
cards will also go up similar to what
happened with the 8700 k so if you guys
are interested in this GPU then make
sure to preorder as soon as you can in
order to be able to snatch it at a fair
price but that's all I have for you guys
this time make sure to post what you
guys are thinking in the comments down
below like do you think this GPU won't
do anything or do you think this GPU
will provide gamers with a viable
options for 1080p
I do read all my comments and I am
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts ask for
NVIDIA ampere you guys are interesting
that then I have a dedicated view about
that as well to make sure to check that
out if you guys are interested if you
guys like this video then make sure to
drop a like on this video and smash the
subscribe button if you guys would like
to see more videos just like this but
that's all I have for you guys this time
until next video
[Music]